Beto O'Rourke is desperately trying to
reboot his campaign after bottoming out
in the polls but it's not going so well
after bombing on the view this week and
apologizing for his privilege Beto
decided to get back to his roots
remember when he live-streamed his trip
to the dentist well lucky for us Beto is
back with another bizarre video check it
out cutting out some of this your hair
that you Dana well that's probably true
[Laughter]
again there's a lot a fine line between
goofy and incompetent it's really
interesting from hero to zero in about
20 seconds so he was he came on strong
when he had the six million dollars in
one day type of thing but the Democrats
really wanted him to stay in Texas and
run for Senate against Cornyn because he
had taken on Ted Cruz and he didn't
really come that close against Ted Cruz
but closer than other Democrats had been
and now I think that it's becoming
pretty clear that he's you might be good
at running for Senate but he's not good
at running for president and not in with
this crowd great yo he's trying to make
himself seem real and authentic and
every time you do that you come off
looking desperate and thirsty he should
be happy that he married up and rich and
stop parading his myriad flaws to it the
embarrassment of all you know the view I
believe really provided the kill shot
that turned him into a shamed schoolboy
whose jacket didn't fit and he was like
a mumbling beta male who will definitely
write about it in his dream journal when
he gets out women know this guy from
college right every woman has so he
lures you in the dorm with this illusion
of depth his you know collection of
Camus and in poetry skateboard wade
board and what do you like in the doors
there you go yeah yeah yeah but then in
like in three months you realize put it
I waste my time well yeah you could play
him in a movie Jessie then your best
interest to have him have a long run
that's true that is true I think
interesting people assume other people
think they're interesting and it's
usually not the case a lot of the times
you don't want to see what's under the
hood or how the sausage is made or you
know those you don't want us to go
behind the curtain always sometimes the
curtain is there for a reason
it's a reality show he's running not a
presidential campaign this I read the
Vanity Fair piece today and this woman
said that bado reminds all American
women about a bad boyfriend and I think
that's pretty much the key politicians
are successful when they use imagery
wealth to enhance their look the image
of him with his mouth hanging open or
his wet hair over his forehead or the
air hair that those images right there
those are the kind of presidential
images that do many campaign this is
like he's volunteering to put the
Dukakis helmet on in the tank and he
thinks it's winning well the thing is
you know in this current iteration of
American politics as we approach 2020
you know social media and authenticity
are a really interesting dynamic mix and
so you see people doing this stuff and
the beer and every of the games and
lifting weights and everything else so
let me just tell you this so right now
he's not doing that well in the polls I
think he qualifies to get on the debate
stage but he's not rising and part of
this is interesting where he is winning
is on Instagram Instagram people he is
the biggest Instagram following of
anybody and that's a younger group of
people and apparently they like this
stuff I don't think that represents the
universe of Democrats in the country
obviously you see Biden rising you see
Pete Buddha judge by the way taking a
lot of his theme why because I think
people judge is not running a social
media campaign he's actually going out
and winning a national campaign he does
better on the view better on Ellen
better all right so people to judge his
social media game is strong because of
his her husband Cheston and his dogs
Truman and Buddy have their own
Instagram account and by the way people
would more likely vote for those two
dogs and they'd vote for better or rock
at this point well Gregg said this the
other day you
should be running for president of
Instagram or Twitter regular Americans
out there that want to hear from you did
I say that I don't think it was me I
just repackaged it better thank you
you're welcome
quickly how long for you drops out you
think oh I think I'll go to Iowa oh yeah
I do I mean they have enough money and
enough staff like what's the incentive
to drop out it's rich he's got nothing
to do yeah he'll stand on some counter
tops there yeah